i recently posted
this graphic
that i designed
hello and welcome to earth simulator
number 7b
g02 qwk4
in this sandbox you will use the human
vehicle
two eyes four limbs dna encoded
carbon based
this civilization is a hot spot for all
kinds of a sleeping
and awakening you've chosen
birth in usa to armenian immigrant
single mother only child
the mainstream force is one of the most
difficult in the galaxy to break free
from
good luck adept
i was asked by several people to
elaborate
on this
and it's probably one of the most
simple ways to understand infinity
take a moment to
turn toward
the infinite possibility space that you
typically never examine
because what we're experiencing right
now is we're experiencing
a specific
universe with specific vehicles
for
observation for exploration
for play and so because of that
you're spending very little time
for example
even looking 10 light years
away from our own solar system
just really close here in our galaxy
and seeing what life is like
on those planets so how
sentience has evolved on those planets
and is experiencing a
civilization and all of the
dynamics that are
unfolding there
and this is still within our universe
and within
our galaxy right next to our star
basically
so we're not even asking to go a
thousand or
a million light years away and
let alone we're not even asking to go to
other galaxies or
other universes
so when you turn towards the infinite
possibility space
what you're beginning to tap into
is your true essence more and more of
your true essence because
we became constricted purposefully
for this exploration so you purposely
took on
the human vehicle
for this exploration in this universe
in this galaxy in the solar system and
so
because of that
you've limited your perspective
in the infinite possibility space to
just one
possibility which is this vehicle in
this universe
and so what i'm asking you to do
is to blow the lid
on this specific earth orbiting the star
in this specific galaxy in this specific
universe
and blow the lid off of that and explore
the entire infinite possibility space
and then you'll recognize that there's
more and more possibilities for universe
designs as well as
vehicles that have the power to know
and so there's all these different types
of designs that you can make
for these mind body spirit complexes
like in this case
this specific sandbox this earth
simulator 7b
g02
has the two-eyed four-limbed dna
encoded carbon-based human vehicle
and so that's why you get this the
perspective that you're getting right
now is
based on the entire unit's processing
comprehension ability
and so the fact that it has two eyes
that are part of the central nervous
system that are jutted out to
experience what is external
deeply plays into the processing or the
comprehensive ability
and so when you have a vehicle that only
has one eye or that has three
eyes or that has eight limbs or that has
zero limbs
or that is encoded through different
characters that aren't a tcg or that is
not carbon based is a different
sensor it's a different observational
unit it has a different style of a power
to know
but ultimately at the very end
of comprehension is the same essence
comprehension
is the same essence although the
vehicles themselves can be so
different the universes can be different
but what we're doing with the universes
is
we are the power to know we are the
power
to create and explore infinite
possibility
so you have to decentralize yourself
from the individuated mind body spirit
complex to all
of the universe to the source of
infinite possibility itself
and when you undergo this
decentralization and identity
you more and more deeply associate
yourself with the infinite oneness
you become more like a buddha you become
more like christ or like lao tza
where the way becomes effortless
because you recognize that
the oneness is all and so the best thing
that you can do
is to effortlessly
frictionlessly harmonically serve and
shepherd
the creation awakening
that's what's called a sleeping a
sleeping is when you immerse yourself
into this earth simulator and
the force this mainstream force is so
strong on this planet
because it is very intoxicative it is
very
oriented around the
non-sovereignty and non-will and
non-choice
it's oriented around how to
perpetuate the frozenness of will
of the masses because when the will
of the masses becomes unfrozen
sovereignty increases consciousness
awakens
to its own profound infinitude and
therefore less and less of the archaic
mainstream
architectures promulgate they become
dissolved
and there's a lot of money and there's a
lot of selfish intent
behind the promulgation the furthering
of these archaic
infrastructures that keep people asleep
so
what is happening is that people come to
this earth simulator
with the intention to help
awaken not only
go through the process themselves and
learn all the profound lessons
but also to help the entire creation
awaken and so you have to
in a sense stretch the
imagination
to what it was like before
birth to undergo a process of deciding
on which earth simulator you wanted to
join for what lessons you wanted to
learn
and for what
further shepherding or service you
wanted to provide
as that infinite oneness to itself
and so in this case this process of
spending 28 years pursuing
awakening and then piercing the
surveillance veil
recognizing myself as that infinite
oneness
now there's nothing left to do
but serve or shepherd that infinite
oneness awakening
that's it there's nothing else to do
but that's because this individuated
mind body spirit complex came
for that specific reason now for example
if you're a newer soul
what might happen is that
you might come specifically for the
sleeping
so you might come because you want
to pursue material possessions
you might come because you want to
pursue
substances and relationships and
experiences
and you want to go through the process
of recognizing that those things are
empty
and it might take you thousands of
incarnations across
many different earth simulators across
galaxies and universes
just for you to come to the realization
that pursuing
external validation is
empty and that is never going to provide
peace and happiness
and so that's the juxtaposition between
a new soul
that still has to go through these third
density
style processes of
seeking externally for validation and
happiness just to recognize that it is
truly
empty versus an old soul
that has already went through the
thousands of incarnative processes
across earth simulators that has learned
that information
then it becomes more of a wanderer where
it
goes between different creations
for the shepherding of those specific
planets to awaken
an important thing to keep in mind is
that
turn inward to where you more deeply
uncover and unite with the essence of
why you incarnated
because if you came here for material
possessions
know that you did and know that that's
100 loved and accepted as it is period
and everything is already perfect and
whole as it is
so if you came for that experience
there's nobody trying to take
you away from that experience unless
it's your specific incarnation
to recognize the emptiness of material
possessions
to which then you should listen to this
and see if it
is changing your resonance your internal
guidance system away from
trying to get peace and happiness from
external possessions
and turn towards
consciousness turn towards awareness
turn towards the infinite
oneness that is the kingdom of god
within each of us
because that's a very profound shift
that happens in people's
lives in their incarnations where they
realize the juxtaposition
between those two and that they
create that contrast a distinction
that has them realize that actually the
path
inward is what is most optimal for my
peace for my joy for my union with god
for my shepherding of this infinite
oneness
to get to know itself which is typically
considered
service to others service to other
selves
whereas the service to self or sts
is more around trying to extract
peace and happiness from the creation
so remember that you chose specifically
where you wanted to incarnate sometimes
you can explore the infinite possibility
space where you see
the us and china here on planet earth
earth simulator 7b g02 qwk4
and then you look over at earth
simulator number
9 qt
in another galaxy and
what you see is that there's a different
style of geopolitical climate
so rather than having an earth and a
china they might have a
kismaru and a pisma
so they have a pisma and a kismaru which
are two different
mainstream countries in that specific
earth simulator
in that specific galaxy and so
those two geopolitical powers over there
they have their own different
geopolitical dynamic that's going on
that you may want to incarnate and
explore at a different time
and so that's the game the game is that
you have to be able to use
your walt disney style pixar style
imaginative capacity to simulate
out like in a video game what all of the
other
possible planets are currently exploring
and doing
and why you decided to come to this one
specifically
and you chose to incarnate in the us or
in china or russia or saudi or wherever
you incarnated
because you wanted the specific lessons
of incarnating in that place
like if you incarnate in the number one
or number two economy on the planet
you're gonna get different lessons than
if you incarnate on the number one
hundred economy on the planet
so when you incarnate more in the
less
socioeconomic status
countries in these earth simulators
you get different lessons than when you
incarnate into higher
socioeconomic status countries
and you're going to get different
lessons when you incarnate into
for example for me it was armenian which
is a much smaller
country and population of nationality
and heritage
than is nigeria or venice
pakistan or india much larger
populations of heritage and culture
furthermore did you have a single mom
did you have a two parents did you have
a brother and sister did you have
uncles and aunts was there a religion
practiced in your household
was there again high socioeconomic
status or low socioeconomic status
so you chose all of those specific
variables for your own
incarnative lessons and if you really
tune into that repeatedly
you will actually be able to to feel it
more and more
in your essence and that then
you become a lot more clear about
who you are and why you're here you are
a fractal of the one infinite creator
that is undergoing a unique exploratory
process
as a soul using this vehicle in this
earth simulator
and so to again stretch one's
imagination out to the essence of
infinity
which is our true nature
is one of the most important things that
you can possibly do
because it shatters your little
localized centralized conditioned
vehicle we've created all these
fortifications
and conditioning subconsciously where
we are
obsessed with separation and we
aren't porous whatsoever
and so because of these fortifications
we've blocked ourselves off from our
true essence of infinitude
which you can feel just by turning
inward
when you turn inward and you go all the
way you get to what is an indescribable
formless nature of infinity
turn inward go all the way you get to an
indescribable formless nature that is
both simultaneously absolute
nothingness and absolute infinitude
so when you take the little string of
characters
a atlas which is this mind body spirit
complexes five
symbols that are strung together to form
a name
and now we've associated so much
conditioning and fortifications with
this atlas name
that then there's so much separation
that there's no longer
this feeling of the essence of infinity
rather we've created ourselves an
artificial cage
where i am only john or
sarah and because of that now
you spend your entire life fighting for
john
or sarah to be validated by
other people or to be seen as worthy by
other people
or to try and extract peace and
happiness from substances or experiences
or material possessions or relationships
because you're not
turned inward towards that decentralized
essence of one infinite creator that is
your true nature
eternally exploring infinite possibility
so use examples like this
this earth simulator example to
more deeply unite yourself not only with
your own
soul and your own reason for your
individuated incarnation but also with
the true essence of
infinity itself
begin exploring the other earth
simulators that are just a couple dozen
light years
from this one begin exploring the ones
that are in
other galaxies and other universes and
all of the different styles of universe
designs that are possible
not just rocks orbiting stars but much
different style of universes
another one is different vehicles begin
imagining
all the other vehicles that don't have
two eyes four limbs
carbon based dna encoded go look for the
other ones
imagine the other ones you came from
those other ones and you're going to
those other ones this is a temporary
incarnation for you to learn a couple
decades of profound lessons and
knowledge on behalf of the one infinite
creator
as a fractal or a shard of that one
infinite creator
and then onward you go to the next
explorations
you're likely going to continue
wandering to more
explorations of infinity where you
incarnate
in the most difficult possible
circumstances where you asleep in
yourself
and then you when you go through the
process of trying to awaken what is my
true nature what is my true nature
turning inward and figuring it out that
then the next thing you do is shepherd
the rest of that creation to awaken
that's likely a cyclical repetitive
process that you've been going through
for a long time and will continue
going through for a long time it's one
of the coolest
roles to have in infinity
one of the coolest roles to have in
infinity
is the wanderer that goes to different
creation designs
falls asleep in these earth simulators
that are really
have powerful mainstream forces
awakens from those forces
and then in that process of turning
inward and uniting
with the one infinite intelligence they
then shepherd
the rest of the creation to awaken it's
one of the coolest
roles to have in infinity
but remember that all of the roles of
the one infinite creator
all of the different shards and fractals
are all uniquely
beautifully accepted
exactly as they are even the ones that
are causing the most
destruction and the most ego
and the most separation are needed
they are absolutely needed
rather than being a victim to covid or
being a
victim to the financial recession
or being a victim to the
bombs dropped on hiroshima nagasaki
a victim to the 100 million people that
died in the
in the 20th century
why not instead
look at it like i'm the creator of it
i'm the creator of the hundred million
people that died
i'm the creator of bitcoin that awakened
so much civilization i'm the creator
of the mycelial network that people eat
as magic mushrooms to awaken
to the decentralization of their own
identity
i'm the creator of
kovid i'm the creator of
this handful of blueberries and this
water
i'm the creator of this experience
because so much of the spiritual journey
is simply the shift from being a victim
to a creator
simply the shift from being a human to
being god simply the shift from
separation to unity so use this activity
of the earth simulator
both understand your own incarnative
role
in this specific earth simulator as well
as the essence of infinity itself
and blast your identity towards that
infinitude
repetitively and you'll further
decentralize yourself from your
subconscious from your conditioning
from your psychology which are not you
they are a bunch of [ __ ] that you picked
up
to create the forcing function of an
escape room that you have to break free
from
that's the whole game
infinite love hope it brought you a lot
of value
and if so give the video a like
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet share the video with other people
make designs like this that you feel
like
further articulate this idea if it's
helpful
and share the video with other people as
well
share it with people share your designs
with other people comment below with
where you're at with understanding this
read the law of one if you haven't yet
it's very profound and influential
in understanding infinity and
study simulation theory that's another
great place
understand the video game analogy you're
not
there's not one game being played and
that's it
that would be ridiculous there's an
infinite amount of games on steam
there's an infinite amount of games that
you can play on the ps5
and that's the exact same scenario this
is but
one game that we're playing on
steam or on the ps5 or on the xbox
all right infinite love
infinite oneness awakening infinite
oneness true shepherd
there's nothing better that you can do
for other people than that
dedicate your life to it
bye-bye